From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Here's a question we get asked all the time. How do you change someone's behavior? Now, awesome would it be if you, the victim, decided to not get upset? Experts trying to change the way we live our lives. The biggest single cause of global warming, along with deforestation, which is 20% of it, is the burning of fossil fuels. Oil is a problem and coal is the most serious problem.
来自NPR，这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这是一个我们经常被问到的问题：你如何改变一个人的行为？如果你，也就是受害者，决定不生气，那该有多棒啊？专家们正试图改变我们生活的方式。全球变暖的单一最大成因，连同占20%的森林砍伐，是化石燃料的燃烧。石油是一个问题，而煤炭则是最严重的问题。
Presidents trying to reshape our culture. For we have a choice in this country, we can accept a politics that breeds division or we can come together and say, not this time. We like to think we change people's behavior through information, through education, through persuasion. Now, these things often don't work, but we keep doing them because we have an unshakable faith in a core assumption about human nature.
总统们正试图重塑我们的文化。因为在这个国家我们有一种选择，我们可以接受助长分裂的政治，或者我们可以团结起来说，这次绝不。我们总喜欢认为我们是通过信息、教育和说服来改变人们的行为的。然而，这些方法往往不管用，但我们却一直在做，因为我们对关于人性的核心假设有着不可动摇的信念。
If you want to shape how people behave, you must first change the way they think. Today we look at a very different approach. One that will take us on a journey from the outskirts of Budapest in 1944 to the hills of Rwanda a half century later. This week on Hidden Brain, how to change behavior, it's not what you think. When Irvin's style was a small child, his family had a living caretaker named Maria Gogan. Irvin had his own name for her. We call her March, which is an abbreviation of the Hungarian word Marchka, which means cat. That's because much told Irvin and his sister bedtime stories, and sometimes, as she told these stories, she'd curl up at the foot of the bed and fall asleep.
如果你想塑造人们的行为，你必须首先改变他们的思维方式。今天我们来看一种截然不同的方法。它将带领我们开启一段旅程，从1944年布达佩斯市郊到半个世纪后的卢旺达山丘。本周的“隐藏的大脑”，如何改变行为，它并非你想的那样。欧文·斯陶布很小的时候，家里有一位名叫玛丽亚·戈甘的生活保姆。欧文给她起了个专属名字。我们叫她马奇，这是匈牙利语玛奇卡（Marchka）的简称，意思是猫。那是因为马奇会给欧文和他姐姐讲睡床故事，有时，在讲这些故事的时候，她会蜷缩在床尾睡着。
Outside that cozy house, things were very different. Irvin faced a dangerous world. You see, Irvin was not just a six-year-old child, but... A six-year-old Jewish child, of course. Hungary was not a friendly place to be Jewish. Since the 1920s, the Hungarian government had passed a series of anti-Jewish laws, restricting Jews from certain occupations, stripping them of the right to vote, prohibiting intermarriage with non-Jews.
在那间温馨的房子外面，情况却大不相同。欧文面对的是一个危险的世界。你看，欧文不仅仅是一个六岁的孩子，而是……当然，是一个六岁的犹太儿童。匈牙利对犹太人来说并不是一个友好的地方。自20世纪20年代以来，匈牙利政府通过了一系列反犹法律，限制犹太人从事某些职业，剥夺他们的选举权，禁止与非犹太人通婚。
When World War II erupted, Irvin and his family were in grave danger. Irvin remembers walking with March, pushing his little sister down the street in a baby carriage. He heard a massive rumbling and turned to see German tanks rolling down the street. In 1944 Germans occupied the country. With the help of hundreds of thousands of Hungarian citizens, they rounded up the country's dues. As nearly half a million people were dragged off to places like Auschwitz, most Hungarians did nothing to help. They simply watched as their friends and neighbors disappeared. Irvin's father was captured. Young Irvin might have faced the same fate, but someone intervened to help.
当第二次世界大战爆发时，欧文和他的家人处于极度危险之中。欧文记得自己曾和马奇一起散步，推着小妹妹坐在婴儿车里。他听到一阵巨大的轰鸣声，转头看到德国坦克正沿着街道驶来。1944年，德国占领了这个国家。在数十万匈牙利公民的帮助下，他们搜捕了全国的犹太人。当近五十万人被拖到奥斯威辛等集中营时，大多数匈牙利人却袖手旁观。他们只是眼睁睁地看着自己的朋友和邻居消失。欧文的父亲被抓了。年轻的欧文可能也会面临同样的命运，但有人出手相助了。
It was Maria, or much. She took my sister and me into hiding with a Christian family. To feed the children and their mother, much would carry large amounts of dough and the baby carriage to the bakery and then come back with freshly baked loaves. But one day Hungarian Nazis saw all the bread that she was carrying and they got suspicious. They stopped her.
那是玛丽亚，也就是马奇。她带着我和姐姐去一个基督教家庭躲藏。为了养活孩子们和他们的母亲，马奇会用婴儿车把大量面团运到面包店，然后带回刚烤好的面包。但有一天，匈牙利纳粹看到了她携带的所有面包，他们起了疑心。他们拦住了她。
They told her that if she's going to have juice, she will be killed, had her stand at the wall with her hands up for a very long time. Eventually a man from the neighborhood, a well-respected Hungarian Nazi, saw what was happening and he told the others to stop. One might think that after such a terrifying experience, March might have stopped helping the stop family, but she kept on. And she continued to do the same thing for the rest of the time.
他们告诉她，如果她敢藏犹太人就会被杀，并让她举起双手靠墙站了很长时间。最终，邻居里的一个男人、一个备受尊敬的匈牙利纳粹看到了这一幕，他叫其他人停手。人们可能会认为，经历了如此恐怖的经历后，马奇可能会停止帮助这个犹太家庭，但她坚持了下来。在接下来的时间里，她继续做着同样的事。
March also found out where Irvin's father was being held in a forced labor camp. She went there and approached the wire fencing. She asked someone to summon Irvin's dad. Through the fence, she told him where she had taken the children. So when the whole group from this forced labor camp was taken to Germany, they had a stopover in Budapest, and during that stopover my father escaped. His father found the house with Irwin and his sister. They all hid together and managed to survive the war. Erwin is very sure that March saved his life and the lives of his immediate family. Other relatives who didn't have someone like March to help them perished.
马奇还打听到了欧文的父亲被关押在一个强制劳改营里。她去了那里，走近铁丝网。她请人把欧文的父亲叫出来。隔着栅栏，她告诉他她把孩子们带到了哪里。所以当这个强制劳改营的所有人被带往德国时，他们在布达佩斯中转，正是在那次中转期间，我父亲逃跑了。他的父亲找到了收留欧文和他姐姐的房子。他们全躲在一起，设法在战争中存活了下来。欧文非常确信马奇救了他的命和他直系亲属的性命。其他没有像马奇这样的人帮忙的亲戚都丧生了。
My father's sister and her two children were killed in Auschwitz. My mother's sister's husband, my uncle, died in a forced labor camp. As Irwin grew up, he found himself dwelling on the question, why do people do terrible things to one another? And is it possible to stop them? Irwin eventually got a PhD in psychology from Stanford and taught clinical psychology at Harvard University. All the while, he kept researching how the Nazis dehumanize the Jews as a stepping stone to genocide. He studied the factors that led to Hitler's rise and Nazi ideology. Evil leaders can get people riled up, but the spark of hate usually doesn't turn into a fire, unless people are also experiencing difficult life conditions.
我父亲的姐姐和她的两个孩子在奥斯威辛遇害。我母亲的姐夫，也就是我的叔叔，死在了一个强迫劳改营里。随着欧文长大，他发现自己常常纠结于这样一个问题：为什么人们会对彼此做出可怕的事情？这有可能被阻止吗？欧文最终获得了斯坦福大学的心理学博士学位，并在哈佛大学教授临床心理学。在此期间，他一直致力于研究纳粹如何将犹太人去人性化，以此作为通往种族灭绝的踏脚石。他研究了导致希特勒崛起和纳粹意识形态的因素。邪恶的领导人可以煽动民众，但仇恨的火花通常不会燃成大火，除非人们同时也经历着艰难的生活状况。
So if Germany had not been in the terrible state that it was in, losing a war, a revolution, people in groups fighting on the streets for years, a tremendous depression. If Germany hadn't had that combined with a history of devaluation of Jews, then it is unlikely that Hitler would have been heard. It's unlikely that Hitler's maniacal intense, but charismatic capacity to talk to people would have had the kind of effects that he did.
所以，如果德国没有处于那种糟糕的状态——输掉了一场战争、一场革命、人们在街头厮杀多年、经历了巨大的萧条；如果德国没有这种状况，再加上贬低犹太人的历史，那么希特勒的声音就不太会被人听到。希特勒那狂热、强烈但又具有煽动群众的个人魅力，就不太可能产生他当时所产生的那种效果。
So yes, evil people are important, but not alone. Bad leaders don't alone create it. Irwin developed a theory of how genocide comes about. As leaders spread hateful ideologies and as people get used to ostracizing others, hostility between groups slowly evolves into violence. Urban came up with a term for this gradual process, the continuum of destruction. Violence evolves. There is experimental research that shows that when a person engages in violent action, they are likely to engage in more and greater violence.
所以，是的，邪恶的人很重要，但并非孤立存在。坏领导人并不能单枪匹马地造就这一切。欧文提出了一个关于种族灭绝如何产生的理论。随着领导人传播充满仇恨的意识形态，随着人们习惯于排挤他人，群体之间的敌意慢慢演变成暴力。欧文为这个渐进的过程想出了一个术语：毁灭连续体。暴力是会演变的。有实验研究表明，当一个人参与暴力行为时，他们很可能会卷入更多、更严重的暴力。
In studying a variety of genocide and mass killings, I saw this in every case that people get devalued. The evaluation is justified in terms of the ideology, in reference to the ideology that these people stand in the way of us creating this better world. So this is very important to understand and very important to try to counteract. Irvin tried to imagine what might have stopped this much to violence. on direct. Irvin tried to imagine what might have stopped this march to violence. From his own experience, he knew that active bystanders can have a huge impact in saving the lives of victims.
在研究了各种种族灭绝和大规模屠杀后，我在每一个案例中都看到了这一点，即人们被贬低。这种贬低根据意识形态得到了合理的解释，也就是参照这种意识形态，认为这些人阻碍了我们创造这个更美好的世界。所以这一点非常重要，必须去理解，也必须努力去对抗。欧文试图想象是什么能够阻止这场通往暴力的游行。从他自己的经验中，他知道积极的旁观者在拯救受害者生命方面可以产生巨大的影响。
But in any conflict, why do some bystanders choose to intervene while so many others stay silent? Why had March taken such great risks to save Erwin and his family? I think she did it because she loved us, because she was connected to us, because she saw other human beings and didn't accept and go along with the devaluation of Jews that was part of the society at that time. Close personal relationships between Jews and Christians could inoculate people against stereotypes and prejudice. The close relationship that March had had with him and his family made it possible for
但在任何冲突中，为什么有些旁观者选择介入，而其他许多人却保持沉默？为什么马奇要冒那么大的风险去拯救欧文和他的家人？我想她这么做是因为她爱我们，因为她与我们紧密相连，因为她把其他人看作人类，并且不接受、不顺从当时社会中贬低犹太人的做法。犹太人和基督徒之间亲密的个人关系可以使人们免受刻板印象和偏见的侵害。马奇与他和他的家人之间曾经建立的紧密关系，使得她能够
her to see Jews as human beings worthy of protection. At a very young age, she was sent out to work as a servant in other families. And she made very good connections to children, and I think to the people she worked for, and she received a lot of love and care from these children back in return for her love. That was a very important healing experience on her part. So all of these things I think contributed to the kind of person she became and her openness and readiness to be altruistic. Irvin felt that his personal experiences provided a roadmap to combat hatred.
把犹太人看作是值得保护的人类。很小的时候，她就被送去其他家庭当佣人。她和孩子们建立了很好的联系，我想也和她工作过的人建立了联系，而且她从这些孩子们那里得到了很多爱与关怀，作为对她付出的爱的回报。对她而言，那是一次非常重要的治愈经历。所以我想，所有这些因素共同造就了她那样的人，以及她乐于助人的开放性和准备状态。欧文觉得他的个人经历为对抗仇恨提供了一张路线图。
He started to think about how to inoculate people against hate speech and intolerance. He traveled the world, sharing his ideas at academic conferences. He became a renowned expert on the causes of genocide. You know, when this process begins, when a society begins to harm some group and devalues it more and justifies it and then creates creates institutions, and there is this evolution. The only thing that can stop it is active by standards. People who are witnesses, who see what is happening,
他开始思考如何让人们对仇恨言论和不容忍产生免疫。他游历世界，在学术会议上分享自己的想法。他成为了研究种族灭绝成因的知名专家。你知道的，当这个进程开始时，当一个社会开始伤害某些群体并进一步贬低它、将其合理化，然后建立机构时，就会出现这种演变。唯一能阻止它的，就是积极的旁观者。那些作为见证者、看到正在发生的事情、
and who feel a responsibility, and who begin to take action against it. And unfortunately, much of the time on a whole scale, this doesn't happen. But there are wonderful instances when it does. And there are many examples of even single individuals doing things that changes the course of a society. Fifty years after March saved Irvin's life, he began hearing about an unfolding disaster in the East African country of Rwanda.
感到责任感、并开始采取行动反对它的人。不幸的是，在大多数情况下，从宏观规模来看，这种情况并没有发生。但也有一些精彩的特例。并且有很多例子表明，哪怕是个人也能做出改变社会走向的事情。在马奇救了欧文性命五十年后，他开始听到关于东非国家卢旺达正在发生的一场灾难的消息。
A radio station was broadcasting urgent messages to the population of 7 million. Very few recordings of these broadcasts exist today. Here's one. has exists today, here's one. Rwanda belongs to those who truly defended and you, the cockroaches, are not Rwandans. The cockroaches will not escape. Let us rejoice, my friends. The cockroaches were exterminated. God is never unfair.
一个广播电台正在向700万人口滚动播放紧急信息。如今这类广播的录音已经所剩无几。这里有一个。今天仍然存在的录音，这里有一个。卢旺达属于那些真正捍卫它的人，而你们这些蟑螂，不是卢旺达人。蟑螂是逃不掉的。让我们欢呼吧，我的朋友们。蟑螂已经被消灭了。上帝绝不不公。
Just as the Nazis portrayed Jews as subhuman, the Rwandan government dominated by the Hutu group dehumanized the Tutsi minority. Their weapon of choice, radio, or a some call it hate radio The broadcast had a real effect one Harvard study calculated that hate radio Convinced an additional 50,000 people to murder their neighbors human rights experts Samantha power described the scene this way killers often carried a machete in one hand and a transistor radio in the other. I was 29. I had to move by night, you know, freeing through bushes under whatever.
正如纳粹将犹太人描绘成非人一样，由胡图族主导的卢旺达政府也将图西族少数群体非人化。他们选择的武器是收音机，或者有人称之为“仇恨广播”。这些广播产生了实际效果，一项哈佛的研究估算，仇恨广播说服了另外5万名平民去谋杀他们的邻居。人权专家萨曼莎·鲍尔这样描述当时的场景：凶手通常一手拿着砍刀，另一手拿着晶体管收音机。当时我29岁，我必须在夜间行动，你知道的，穿过灌木丛，在各种掩护下逃生。
This is Andre Musagara. During the genocide, Andre lived in Kigali, Rwanda's capital city. He talked to us on Skype from Rwanda. He told me armed men came to his house and dragged everyone outside. During the genocide, they remember they took us outside holding our hands up. I don't know why they came. We had bruised the doors and the curtains they put on. Andre fully expected to be killed.
这是安德烈·穆萨加拉。在种族灭绝期间，安德烈住在卢旺达首都基加利。他在卢旺达通过Skype接受了我们的采访。他告诉我，武装人员闯入他的家中，把所有人拖到外面。在种族灭绝期间，他们记得他们把我们带到外面，举起双手。我不知道他们为什么来。我们砸了门和他们挂上的窗帘。安德烈原本以为自己必死无疑。
I don't know what prevented them from killing us, because they were having traditional waypans and whatever. I was not killed. I asked Andre how many people came to his house with machetes. He had a hard time answering. I couldn't even look at them, straightening the eyes. They were so terrible. It's like they didn't want anyone to identify them,
我不知道是什么阻止了他们杀死我们，因为他们带着传统武器和其他东西。我没有死。我问安德烈有多少人带着砍刀来到他家。他很难回答。我甚至不敢直视他们的眼睛。他们太可怕了。就好像他们不想让任何人认出他们一样，
so they would sing lay down and they would do one. Yeah. It was a hard moment. I had the moment. A pebble in the African state of Rwanda. This is all the more serious. This is all the more serious. This is all the more serious. This is all the more serious.
所以他们会唱着歌躺下，然后动手。是的。那是一个艰难的时刻。我经历了那一刻。非洲国家卢旺达的一块卵石。这更加严重。这更加严重。这更加严重。这更加严重。
This is all the more serious. The right cross puts the death trial in the tens of thousands. Almost a half million tutuses and moderate Hutus have been massacred from the hands of drunk youngsters carrying machetes and soldiers. Is it genocide and what is being done to stop the killing? I don't want to remember about this. By the time the Rwandan patriotic front defeated the Huto government a few months later, the country was in ruins.
这更加严重。右路进攻使死亡人数达到数万。近五十万图西人和温和派胡图族人惨死在手持砍刀的醉酒年轻人和士兵手中。这是种族灭绝吗？为了制止杀戮正在采取什么行动？我不想再回忆这件事了。几个月后，当卢旺达爱国阵线击败胡图族政府时，这个国家已经满目疮痍。
As many as a million people had been murdered, the majority of the Tootsie population was dead. Many of their killers were roaming free. And now the nation had to rebuild. How can a country come back from such devastation? Would it ever be possible to rebuild trust? For Irwin's tab, it all seemed eerily familiar. A genocide had unfolded, and yet again, the world had sat on its hands and done nothing. I remember seeing pictures of bodies of people killed floating down rivers.
多达一百万人被杀害，大部分图西族人口已经死亡。许多凶手仍在逍遥法外。现在这个国家必须重建。一个国家如何能从如此毁灭性的打击中恢复过来？重建信任真的可能吗？对欧文·斯陶布来说，这一切看起来似曾相识。一场种族灭绝已经上演，而世界却又一次袖手旁观，什么也没做。我记得看到过人们遇害后的尸体顺着河流漂下的照片。
And I do remember being very upset that nobody was doing anything. The community of nations wasn't doing anything. That the United States was stepping aside. Many countries weren't just stepping aside. They were actively turning a blind eye. In Rwanda, when the genocide began, many countries sent in military missions to take their own nationals out. The evacuation of American citizens is proceeding smoothly.
我确实记得当时非常沮丧，因为没有人采取任何行动。国际社会没有采取任何行动。美国正在退居一旁。许多国家不仅在退居一旁，他们还在积极地睁一只眼闭一只眼。在卢旺达，种族灭绝刚开始时，许多国家派遣军事特派团撤走他们自己的国民。美国公民的撤离正在顺利进行。
French troops have entered the capital of Kigathe to evacuate French nationals. Belgian troops are reported to be on say. Some 300 US Marines are standing by in Burunding to help with evacuations, if needed. They flew them out and in a sense communicated to the perpetrators that we are not involved, you are free to do whatever you do. If we completely exterminate the cockroaches, nobody in the world will judge us. Irvin had been speaking at conferences around the world about the causes of genocide, the trauma faced by survivors, and how to work toward reconciliation. But the news from Rwanda told him it was time to try to put into action the theories he had spent decades developing.
法军已进入基加利首都以撤离法国公民。据报道比利时军队也在路上。大约300名美国海军陆战队员在布隆迪待命，以在需要时协助撤离。他们把这些人空运出去，并在某种程度上向施暴者传达了这样一个信息：我们不参与，你们可以随心所欲地做你们想做的事。如果我们彻底消灭了蟑螂，世界上没有人会审判我们。欧文一直在世界各地的会议上发表关于种族灭绝成因、幸存者所经历的创伤以及如何致力于和解的演讲。但来自卢旺达的消息告诉他，是时候把他花了几十年时间发展的理论付诸实践了。
Simply giving speeches was not enough. Irvin felt he had to act. He and his partner, Trauma Specialist Laurie Pearlman, got on a plane and went to Rwanda. There was a real risk that violence could flare up again. We definitely, clearly, went with the intention of creating the program that tries to help, that tries to promote healing, tries to promote reconciliation, so that people live better lives and tries to prevent future violence. Preventing future violence. It was something that Alphonse Bacussi was thinking about as well.
仅仅发表几次演讲是不够的。欧文觉得自己必须采取行动。他和他的伴侣、创伤专家劳瑞·珀尔曼登上了飞往卢旺达的飞机。暴力再次爆发的风险真实存在。我们绝对、明确地带着这样的初衷前往：创建一个尝试提供帮助、尝试促进治愈、尝试促进和解的项目，以便人们过上更好的生活，并试图防止未来的暴力。防止未来的暴力。这也是阿方斯·巴库西正在思考的事情。
He was director of Rwanda's Conflict Management Department, like every other Rwandan, Alphonse had himself been affected by the genocide. Now even as he came to terms with his own suffering, he was given the task of trying to heal the wounds of his people. I spoke to Alphonse recently on a scratchy phone line to Kigali. That is a kind of a diorama. I have a obligation to connect my people and on the other side, I was one of the affected people. So you are affected and you are asked to hit people. So you're affected but you also have to simultaneously help the people who are affected,
他是卢旺达冲突管理部门的主任，和每一个卢旺达人一样，阿方斯本人也受到了种族灭绝的影响。现在，即便他在努力接受自己所遭受的痛苦时，他也被赋予了试图抚平自己人民伤口的任务。我最近通过一条杂音不断的电话线与远在基加利的阿方斯进行了交谈。那有点像是一个透视画。我有义务去联系我的人民，而在另一方面，我也是受害者之一。所以你既是受害者，又被要求去治愈别人。所以你受了伤，但你同时也必须去帮助那些受害的人，
other people who are affected. That is why I'm saying about the Hidma. As he battled his dilemma, Alphonse dug deep into his past back to happier days before the genocide. He went back to his time in college, in high school. And he remembered one thing that he had loved as a student. The theater. The festival in my second at the school I used to play some drama. I was in... I was one of the sentimental acts in my team. It was clear that radio could convince people to be violent. Rwandan officials, Irvin and a production team led by a Dutch NGO, Radio Labine Valencia,
其他受害的人。这就是我所说的希德玛（Hidma）。在与这种困境搏斗时，阿方斯深入挖掘了自己的过去，回到了种族灭绝前更加快乐的日子。他回到了自己的大学和高中时代。他记起了一件他作为学生时非常热爱的事。戏剧。我在学校的第二年参加了节日演出，我经常演一些戏剧。我是……我是我们团队里感性派的演员之一。显而易见，广播可以说服人们变得暴力。卢旺达官员、欧文以及由荷兰非政府组织“瓦伦西亚广播实验室”领导的制作团队，
wanted to prove that radio could also bring people together. The idea they came up with? A radio soap opera. Rwandan officials had successfully used an educational drama to teach people how to practice safe sex. Alphonse, Irvin and the production team thought that a radio drama could teach ordinary citizens how to spot and then reverse the early stages of the continuum of destruction. Irvin had about a dozen messages he wanted to sprinkle throughout the show, all were derived from nearly 50 years of research and reflected his own experiences during the Holocaust.
想要证明广播同样能将人们凝聚在一起。他们想出的主意是什么？一部广播肥皂剧。卢旺达官员曾成功地利用一部教育剧来教导人们如何进行安全性行为。阿方斯、欧文和制作团队认为，一部广播剧可以教导普通公民如何识别并随后扭转毁灭连续体的早期阶段。欧文大约有十几条想要穿插在剧中的核心信息，所有这些都源于近50年的研究，并反映了他自己在犹太人大屠杀期间的亲身经历。
We're going to look at three of those messages. First, violence evolves slowly. Genocidal leaders don't always start out planning to commit genocide. At the beginning, they are not so committed. The vision that we are going to kill these people is not there. That evolves part of this evolution. Point number two, bystanders matter. In conditions that lead to great violence by standards have to act early.
我们将探讨其中三条信息。首先，暴力是缓慢演变的。奉行种族灭绝的领导人并不总是一开始就计划实施种族灭绝。在起初，他们并没有那么坚定。我们要杀光这些人的愿景并不存在。那是随着演变过程逐渐产生的。第二点，旁观者至关重要。在导致严重暴力的条件下，旁观者必须尽早采取行动。
Because the later it is, the more leaders and the society gets committed to turning a bouncing harm in these people. Number three, when people form close personal relationships with those from other groups, this provides a barrier to the spread of prejudice. When two people from unfriendly groups marry one another, this can reduce hostility between the groups. Orwin wanted to convey this very simple message. The hope that intermarriage would be a positive thing.
因为越到后来，领导层和整个社会就越会执着于把对这些人的伤害付诸实施。第三点，当人们与来自其他群体的人建立紧密的个人关系时，这就为偏见的蔓延提供了一道屏障。当两个来自不友好群体的人相互通婚时，这可以减少群体之间的敌意。欧文想要传达这个非常简单的信息。希望通婚能成为一件积极的事情。
The production team assembled a group of writers to develop the right narrative. The brainstorming sessions span hours, days, weeks. Ours and Ours and Ours, looking over the hills of Kigali, developing this original radio program. In 2004, one decade after genocide had devastated the country, the program made its debut. It was called... When we come back, we'll hear about the Rwandan love story that captivated a divided country. The question was, would it work? I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is...
制作团队召集了一群编剧来构思正确的叙事。头脑风暴会议持续了数小时、数天、数周。几个小时、几个小时又几个小时，俯瞰着基加利的群山，开发这个原创广播节目。2004年，在种族灭绝蹂躏该国十年后，该节目首次亮相。它的名字叫……当我们回来时，我们将听到关于那个迷恋了一个分裂国家的卢旺达爱情故事。问题是，它会奏效吗？我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是……
Just kidding, this is Hidden Brain. The radio-sopapra mosaic aware, which means New Dawn, was making its debut. The show follows two fictional villages, Muhumoro and Bumanzi, with a backstory that inevitably leads to conflict. Here's producer George Weiss, who led the NGO Radio Lab in Avalencia that launched the program. We located these two places on two hills, opposite one another, and in the middle there is a field, which is fertile, and through some
开个玩笑，这里是“隐藏的大脑”。广播肥皂剧《莫塞卡瓦亚》（Musekeweye），意为“新黎明”，当时正在首播。该剧讲述了两个虚构村庄穆胡莫罗（Muhumoro）和布曼齐（Bumanzi）的故事，其背景故事不可避免地导致了冲突。这是节目制作人乔治·韦斯，他领导了推出该节目的非政府组织“瓦伦西亚广播实验室”。我们将这两个地方设定在两座彼此相对的山丘上，中间有一块肥沃的土地，通过某种
historic injustice was given to the second village, Bumanzi. And then a little catastrophe happens, a bridge collapses, somebody gets killed and people start feeling very insecure. This is in parallel to Irwin Staupp's, what he calls, difficult life conditions. Irwin Staupp knew from his own experience during the Holocaust that difficult life conditions provide fertile soil for hatred to grow. The hope was, in the fictitious conflict between the Muhumoro and the Bomancy, Hutus and Tutsis in the audience would recognize their own story. season the audience would recognize their own story. And they might learn three concrete ways to move past their divisions. As a Rwandan writers and producers created the drama, one member of the team was Andrei Musagara. Yes, that's the same Andrei who survived the genocide,
历史不公，这块土地被分给了第二个村庄布曼齐。然后发生了一场小灾难，一座桥塌了，有人被杀了，人们开始感到非常没有安全感。这与欧文·斯陶布所说的“艰难生活状况”相平行。欧文·斯陶布从自己在犹太人大屠杀期间的亲身经历中知道，艰难的生活状况为仇恨的滋生提供了肥沃的土壤。人们希望，在穆胡莫罗和布曼齐之间的虚构冲突中，受众中的胡图族人和图西族人能够认出他们自己的故事。并且他们或许能学会三种超越分歧的具体方法。当卢旺达的编剧和制作人创作这部剧时，团队的成员之一就是安德烈·穆萨加拉。是的，就是那个在种族灭绝中幸存下来的安德烈，
who didn't know why the men with machetes didn't kill him, who didn't want to be reminded of that traumatic moment. Today, Andre is the director of Mussecawea. So, to some extent, it opened my mind and now I'm different from the guy I was getting yellow-side and even before. Andre and the other Rowan-den-W writers tried to weave psychological messages into their narrative. Violence evolved slowly. Bystanders matter. Intermarriage can reduce conflict.
那个不知道手持砍刀的人为什么没有杀他、那个不愿意被勾起那段创伤回忆的人。如今，安德烈是《莫塞卡瓦亚》的导演。所以，在某种程度上，它开阔了我的眼界，现在的我与那个过去偏执甚至更早之前的我有所不同。安德烈和卢旺达的其他编剧试图将心理学信息编织进他们的叙事中。暴力缓慢演变。旁观者至关重要。通婚可以减少冲突。
Since 2004, there have been more than 700 episodes, each one about 20 minutes long. At a story workshop at the beginning of each season, There have been more than 700 episodes, each one about 20 minutes long. At a story workshop at the beginning of each season, the writers decide how the plot is going to evolve, all while weaving in the messages approved by the academic team they are working with. Rewinded society has worked hard over the past 25 years to try and erase the divisions between Hutu and Tutsi to ensure that tribal rivalries never again put lives in danger. Here I'm speaking with showwriter Charles Rokundo. Can I ask you I don't know if this is appropriate to ask you or not so forgive me if it's not appropriate but were you from the Hutu community or the Tutsi community?
自2004年以来，该剧已经播出了700多集，每集大约20分钟。在每个季度初的故事工作坊上，编剧们会决定情节将如何发展，同时巧妙地融入与他们合作的学术团队所批准的信息。在过去的25年里，卢旺达社会一直在努力消除胡图族和图西族之间的隔阂，以确保部落间的好斗永远不会再次将生命置于危险之中。在这里，我正在与剧作家查尔斯·罗昆多对话。请问，我不知道问这个是否合适，所以如果不合适请原谅我，但你来自胡图族社区还是图西族社区？
I'm one that I'm one. I'm one that I'm one. I'm one that. You need one that is very difficult. In Rwanda, it's frowned upon to discuss the who-to-our-tootsie past. In some cases, you can even be jailed under a law prohibiting something called divisionism. The official position of the Rwandan government is that there is no ethnicity there. Everyone is Rwandan. In the soap opera, as hostilities flared between the communities on two opposing hills, the writers needed
我是一个……我是一个。我是一个……我是一个。我是一个。你需要一个……这非常困难。在卢旺达，公开讨论胡图族或图西族的过去是不受欢迎的。在某些情况下，你甚至会因一项禁止某种被称为“分裂主义”行为的法律而被捕。卢旺达政府的官方立场是，那里没有民族之分。每个人都是卢旺达人。在这部肥皂剧中，随着两座对立山头上的社区之间的敌意升级，编剧们需要
characters for listeners to identify with. So on those two hill tops, both alike in dignity, they created a pair of star cross lovers, Shema and Batamurisa. What do you say now? What is the same? We are talking about Batamuris. People are very interested in love. So by telling them this love story, they are easily connected. And through this story, they could learn that above the differences,
让听众产生共鸣的角色。因此，在那些同样尊贵、遥遥相望的山顶上，他们创造了一对命运多舛的情侣，谢马（Shema）和巴塔穆里萨（Batamuriza）。你现在怎么说？有什么一样的？我们在谈论巴塔穆里萨。人们对爱情非常感兴趣。因此，通过讲述这个爱情故事，他们很容易产生共鸣。通过这个故事，他们可以了解到，超越差异，
they can find something to unite the rainbow. Andrei explains that Mosekiawea is a Romeo and Julia type story where young lovers have to battle the animosity their families feel toward each other. Just like Shakespeare's Montague's and Capulets, the romance causes all kinds of conflict between the two hills. The show was a runaway success. In Rwanda, nearly everyone listens to the radio and researchers have estimated that most of the population was listening to Musek Awayah. Anyone associated with the show became a big star
他们可以找到将彩虹凝聚在一起的东西。安德烈解释说，《莫塞卡瓦亚》是一个罗密欧与朱丽叶式的故事，年轻的情侣必须与他们家族彼此感到的敌意作斗争。正如莎士比亚笔下的蒙塔古家族和凯普レット家族一样，这段浪漫在两座山头之间引发了各种各样的冲突。这部剧取得了巨大的成功。在卢旺达，几乎每个人都听收音机，研究人员估计绝大多数人口都在收听《莫塞卡瓦亚》。任何与该节目相关的人都成了大明星，
and it seemed like the messages were getting through, at least anecdotally. One of the show's villains is a man named Ruta Ghanira. He's wary of the other side, he thinks they are stealing crops, keeping his village down. The name Ruta Ghanira became used in casual conversation when someone was acting like a jerk. Here's producer George Weiss. Well we heard people describe conflict situations by using the names of our characters. You know, oh you don't be a Ruta Ganeera.
而且至少从轶事来看，这些信息似乎正在传达出去。剧中的大反派之一是一个叫鲁塔·加尼拉（Ruta Ghanira）的人。他防备着另一方，认为他们在偷庄稼，拖累他的村庄。当有人表现得像个混蛋时，“鲁塔·加尼拉”这个名字甚至成了日常对话中的常用语。这是制作人乔治·韦斯。嗯，我们听到人们用我们角色的名字来描述冲突情境。你知道的，“哦，别当鲁塔·加尼拉”。
It seemed like the Rwandans were getting the message. But were they really? How could the show creators know for sure? Enter social scientist Betsy Palak, who is now a professor of psychology at Princeton University. I was sitting in New Haven at Yale University and I found a report about this radio cell bomb right. At the time, Betsy was a graduate student trying to figure out a topic for her PhD field
卢旺达人似乎接收到了这个信息。但他们真的收到了吗？节目创作者怎么能确定呢？社会科学家贝丝·帕拉克闪亮登场，她现在是普林斯顿大学的心理学教授。当时我坐在纽黑门（应为纽黑文）的耶鲁大学里，我发现了一份关于这个广播肥皂剧的报告。当时，贝丝是一名研究生，正试图为她的博士实地研究确定一个选题。
research. She reached out to the show creators. They agreed to work with her to measure whether the show was changing people's beliefs and making them more tolerant toward each other. Betsy wanted to do something very ambitious. Conduct a controlled study in a country that had just been through an incredibly brutal civil war. Remember, the creators of the show wanted to convince Rowandans about three things.
她联系了节目创作者。他们同意与她合作，来衡量该节目是否真的在改变人们的信念，让他们彼此更加包容。贝丝想做一件非常宏大的事：在一个刚刚经历过极其残酷内战的国家进行一项对照研究。请记住，该节目的创作者希望让卢旺达人相信三件事：
Violence evolved slowly, bystanders matter, intermarriage reduces conflict. But were the messages getting through, were Rwandan's adopting these new beliefs? Betsy wanted to measure the changes, and she wanted to know where the ordinary people were treating their fellow citizens differently. We ran it like a medical trial in which we assigned certain communities to listen to this reconciliation soap opera and other communities to listen to a different
暴力缓慢演变，旁观者至关重要，通婚减少冲突。但这些信息真的传达出去了吗？卢旺达人是否在采纳这些新信念？贝丝想要衡量这些改变，她想知道普通公民是否在以不同的方式对待他们的同胞。我们像进行医学试验一样运行它，我们将某些社区指定收听这部和解肥皂剧，而将其他社区指定收听另一部涉及不同主题、特别是艾滋病毒/艾滋病和女性健康的肥皂剧。
soap opera that was about a different topic specifically HIV AIDS and Women's Health. So once a month for an entire year, the Musaikawaya group gathered around a portable stereo and listened. The listened as Batamuriza's father died and Shema came to pay his respects. They listened as Batamuris are fed in love with the forbidden Shema. They listened as heavy rain destroyed a bridge between the hilltops. As Ruta Ghanira's son died from malnutrition, and he blamed the other village for the death. As Ruta Ghanira ran for office and planned to invade the other village. As all this happened, people listened.
因此，整整一年里，每个月一次，《莫塞卡瓦亚》收听小组都会聚集在一个便携式立体声音响周围收听。他们听着巴塔穆里萨的父亲去世，谢马前来悼念；他们听着巴塔穆里萨爱上了本该禁忌的谢马；他们听着暴雨摧毁了山顶之间的桥梁；听着鲁塔·加尼拉的儿子因营养不良而死，而他却将死因归咎于另一个村庄；听着鲁塔·加尼拉竞选公职并计划入侵另一个村庄。这一切发生时，人们都在聆听。
And as is often the case in the Rowanan society, they listened together in groups. They weren't just hearing the story on their own. They were seeing the reactions on the faces of their friends and neighbors. They wept together. They laughed together. They shouted out encouragement when Bhatamurisa was dejected. Ihangane Shah, meaning hold on dear. After one year, Betsy and her team interviewed the volunteers and measured their beliefs.
正如卢旺达社会的常态一样，他们成群结队地一起聆听。他们不仅仅是在独自收听这个故事。他们还在彼此的朋友和邻居脸上看到了反应。他们一起哭泣，一起欢笑。当巴塔穆里萨沮丧时，他们大声喊出鼓励的话：“Ihangane Shah”，意思是“亲爱的，挺住”。一年后，贝丝和她的团队采访了这些志愿者，并对他们的信念进行了测量。
Had they learned the lessons, had their attitudes toward other Rwandans changed? Betsy asked them about Irvin's three ideas that the Rwandan writers were trying to instill. Number one, genocide doesn't happen suddenly. The radio program taught that violence accumulates slowly. It doesn't happen all at once. I saw this in every case. Violence progressively evolves. People get devalued.
他们吸取教训了吗？他们对其他卢旺达人的态度发生改变了吗？贝丝向他们询问了卢旺达编剧们试图灌输的欧文的三大理念。第一点，种族灭绝不是突然发生的。广播节目传导的理念是，暴力是逐渐累积的。它不是一下子发生的。我在每一个案例中都看到了这一点。暴力会逐步演变。人们遭到贬低。
There was just one problem. The listeners in the study? They disagreed. We had a number of people who were in our study who said to us at the end, I don't think that's true. The way the genocide happened for me, it came like a sudden rain. Lesson number two. Bystanders matter.
这里只有一个问题。研究中的听众们怎么说？他们并不同意。我们研究中的许多人在最后对我们说：“我不认为那是真的。对我而言，种族灭绝发生的方式就像一场突如其来的暴雨。”第二课。旁观者至关重要。
It was one of Irvin's most important guiding principles, the thing he had learned from much, the woman who had saved him during the Holocaust. When a society begins to harm some group, the only thing that can stop it is actually bystanders. But here too, the idea that bystanders can make a difference didn't seem to be getting through to listeners. When asked whether bystanders who remain silent bear some responsibility for the evil actions of others, there was no difference between those who'd listened to the soap opera and the control group who hadn't. People essentially did not think that bystanders could make any difference.
这是欧文最重要的指导原则之一，也是他从马奇——那个在大屠杀期间救了他的女人身上学到的东西。当一个社会开始伤害某个群体时，唯一能阻止它的其实是旁观者。但在这里同样，旁观者能发挥作用这一观点似乎并没有被听众真正接受。当被问及保持沉默的旁观者是否对其他人的邪恶行为负有一定责任时，听众与没有听过该肥皂剧的对照组之间没有任何区别。人们本质上不认为旁观者能起到任何作用。
And what about lesson number three? Intermarriage can reduce hostility. That didn't work either. People told Betsy, I don't really believe that ethnic intermarriage will bring peace. I just lived through a genocide where I watched who two men killed their two-seed wives and children. So, you know, I don't personally buy that. On all three counts, the soap opera hadn't changed people's beliefs.
那第三课呢？通婚可以减少敌意。这同样没有奏效。人们告诉贝丝：“我真的不相信民族通婚会带来和平。我刚刚经历了一场种族灭绝，我亲眼看着胡图族丈夫杀害了他们图西族的妻子和孩子。所以，你知道的，我个人并不买账。”在这三个方面，肥皂剧并没有改变人们的信念。
As entertainment, the show was a hit, but as an experiment designed to change hearts and minds, move to traumatized people toward reconciliation, the show was a failure. Mosaic aware was nothing more than a fun soap opera. Or was it? There was one dimension where Betsy found the soap opera did make a positive difference, a big difference. And this dimension was even more important than what people believed.
作为娱乐，这部剧大获成功；但作为一项旨在改变心灵、推动受创群体走向和解的实验，这部剧却是个失败。迷人的《莫塞卡瓦亚》不过是一部有趣的肥皂剧罢了。真的是这样吗？贝丝发现了一个维度，在这个维度上，肥皂剧确实产生了积极的影响，而且影响巨大。这个维度甚至比人们的信念更为重要。
When we come back, why the soap opera was far more successful than it might first appear. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is... Okay fine, hidden brain. We're talking about the Rwandan Radio-Sopara that captivated the country with its stories of love and reconciliation after the genocide. That was the good news. The bad news?
稍后我们回来，揭晓为什么这部肥皂剧远比初看起来要成功得多。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是……好吧，好吧，“隐藏的大脑”。我们正在讨论卢旺达的广播肥皂剧，它以战后关于爱与和解的故事吸引了整个国家。那是好消息。坏消息呢？
Despite the hopes of the creators, the show didn't change people's beliefs. But there was one metric much more important than people's own beliefs, actual behavior. As the writers of the radio drama went out into the world to speak with listeners of the show, they came across people who lived on two hills near Kigali, very similar to the hills portrayed in the show. Here's director Andrei Musagara. If the sop opera was a reflection of real life, this was a reflection of the sop opera. The Hutu and Tutsi inhabitants on the two hills that Andrei visited were just like the Muhumoro and the Bomancy. During the genocide, one group had tried to kill the other.
尽管创作者们抱有期望，但该剧并没有改变人们的信念。但有一个指标比人们自身的信念重要得多，那就是实际行为。当广播剧的编剧们走向世界，与该节目的听众交谈时，他们遇到了居住在基加利附近两座山丘上的人们，这与剧中描绘的山丘非常相似。这是导演安德烈·穆萨加拉。如果说肥皂剧是现实生活的写照，那么这就是肥皂剧的写照。安德烈走访的两座山丘上的胡图族和图西族居民，就如同穆胡莫罗和布曼齐的居民一样。在种族灭绝期间，一个群体曾试图消灭另一个群体。
The Utuheil, during genocide, they went to kill people on the other side and they put the properties under that. And the uptake genocide during this transition or justice process that Utuheil was tried. He's talking about the Kachacha, a series of community courts held in the years following the genocide. It put about 1 million people on trial. There's debate about the specific numbers, but the vast majority of those tried were found guilty, with crimes ranging from vandalism to murder.
胡图族人在种族灭绝期间去杀害另一边的人并霸占了财产。而图西族人在这次过渡或正义进程中对胡图族人进行了审判。他指的是“加查查”（Gacaca），即种族灭绝后几年内举行的一系列社区法庭。它将大约100万人推上了审判席。关于具体数字存在争议，但绝大多数受审者被判有罪，罪名从破坏公物到谋杀不等。
The crime it was not very good between these two hives, but there was one listener of Musetia Waya on one hill and he went to find his colleague from Niyadahir. They said to Gila, they shared the via and they said, no, this should not continue this way. And they decided to reunite there. Here's and they decided to reunite there. Heroes and they succeeded. Life was imitating art. Musekerweyer had characters playing the role of active bystanders, peacemakers.
这两个山头之间的犯罪情况一度不太好，但其中一座山头上有一个《莫塞卡瓦亚》的听众，他去找了他在尼亚达希尔（Niyadahir）的同行。他们对吉拉（Gila）说，他们分享了啤酒并表示：“不，事情不能再这样下去了。”于是他们决定在那里重新团聚。这就是……而且他们成功了。生活在模仿艺术。毛塞克维亚剧中有扮演积极旁观者和和平缔造者的角色。
Now, that was happening in the real hills outside Kigali. Even though Musekerweyer listeners told Betsy Palace research team that bystanders couldn't make a difference, bystanders were stepping up to prevent violence. They united and they were inspired by what they heard from our show Musaikyuea. We are so proud and we are happy that we are playing a significant role in the reconciliation in Guanda. And it was more than just anecdotal. Betsy's data found that even though listeners' beliefs didn't change, their behavior did. Take the question of Intermarriage, for instance.
现在，这正在基加利郊外的现实山丘上发生。尽管《莫塞卡瓦亚》的听众告诉贝丝·帕拉克的团队旁观者无法发挥作用，但旁观者们却挺身而出，以防止暴力发生。他们团结起来，并受到了他们从我们的节目《莫塞卡瓦亚》中听到的内容的启发。我们感到非常自豪和高兴，我们在卢旺达的和解进程中发挥了重要作用。而且这不仅仅是轶事。贝丝的数据发现，尽管听众的信念没有改变，但他们的行为确实改变了。以通婚为例。
Bussecawayer listeners told Betsy's team that they didn't think Intermarriage would lead to peace. But that's not all they said. They said, however, I do think that now we should allow our children to intermarry. I think that this is the thing that Rwandans are doing. We all think it's a good thing moving forward. This is a good example of a distinction between what you personally believe, but what you perceive to be a growing trend. What's fascinating here is that you are finding that the message is in fact not changing
《莫塞卡瓦亚》的听众告诉贝丝的团队，他们不认为通婚会带来和平。但他们的话并没有说完。他们接着说：“然而，我确实认为现在我们应该允许我们的孩子通婚。我认为这是卢旺达人正在做的事情。我们都认为这是向前迈进的好事。”这是个人信念与你所认为的不断增长的趋势之间区别的一个很好的例子。这里最迷人的是，你发现这些信息实际上并没有改变
their own personal opinions, but it's still changing their behavior. That's right. I think if you've reflect on your own behavior, it's hard to find a time when, as you were deciding on what to do, you didn't consider someone else or you didn't consider the reaction that your behavior might draw from someone else. When it comes to changing how people behave, it turns out there is a much more powerful driver than people's own beliefs. People don't always do what they believe, but they usually do what they think everyone else believes.
他们个人的观点，但它仍然改变了他们的行为。没错。我想如果你反思一下自己的行为，很难找到这样一个时刻：当你在决定做什么时，你没有考虑其他人，或者你没有考虑你的行为可能会从其他人那里招致什么样的反应。当谈到改变人们的行为时，事实证明，存在着一个比人们自身信念强大得多的驱动力。人们并不总是按自己所相信的去做，但他们通常会按自己认为所有人都在相信的去做。
We are such social people. If we think that our behavior is going to be really going in the other lane, in the other direction, from what people who matter to us, from what they are doing, that really restrains our behavior. So we might think one thing, but eventually do another, not because we're lemmings, but because we're all trying to kind of move in the same direction with the flock. And if we violate those norms, if we behave in ways that disappoint members of our community, we fear that. And so even if we may believe something different, our behavior will conform to the social norm. In essence, Betsy's research demonstrated that even after just one year, the show was working. Even if it didn't change people's beliefs, it was changing social norms, what people thought was expected of them.
我们是非常社会化的人。如果我们认为自己的行为将真正走上另一条路、走向与那些对我们重要的人所做的事情相反的方向，这真的会约束我们的行为。所以我们可能心里想是一回事，但最终做的又是另一回事，倒不是因为我们盲目跟风，而是因为我们都在试图跟群体朝同一个方向前进。如果我们违反了这些规范，如果我们表现得以让社区成员失望，我们会感到恐惧。因此，即使我们可能持有不同的信念，我们的行为也会顺从社会规范。本质上，贝蒂的研究证明了仅仅一年之后，这个节目就起作用了。即使它没有改变人们的信念，它也在改变社会规范，也就是人们认为别人对他们的期望。
The same thing happens in other contexts. Take, for instance, same-sex marriage in the United States. Hundreds of people were in front of the US Supreme Court this morning waiting. In 2015, the Supreme Court ruled that the US Constitution guarantees the right to marry as a fundamental liberty for both straight and gay couples. And his stored victory for gay rights today. Betsy followed ordinary Americans at the time to see if the court decision changed their own views.
同样的情况也发生在其他语境中。以美国同性婚姻为例。今天上午，数百人等候在美国最高法院门前。2015年，最高法院裁定，美国宪法保障结婚的权利，将其作为同性伴侣和异性伴侣的一项基本自由。这是今天同性恋权利的一场历史性胜利。贝蒂当时追踪了普通的美国人，以查看法院的判决是否改变了他们自己的看法。
Again, people's personal beliefs didn't change, but their behavior did. What moved everyone in the same direction was this perception of whether other Americans support same-sex marriage and whether it would become more accepted in the future. The Supreme Court ruling in effect told people, the United States now believes same-sex marriage is okay. You could still think otherwise, but if you acted in ways that showed you didn't agree with the consensus, you risked being left behind. Even worse, you risked becoming an outcast.
同样，人们的个人信念没有改变，但他们的行为改变了。让所有人朝着同一方向前进的是这样一种看法：其他美国人是否支持同性婚姻，以及它未来是否会变得更加被接受。最高法院的裁决实际上告诉人们，美国现在认为同性婚姻是可以接受的。你可能仍然有不同的想法，但如果你表现出不同意这种共识的行动，你就有被抛弃的风险。更糟糕的是，你可能会成为一个被排挤的人。
And you may remember that time where people's Facebook walls exploded in rainbows. Once the social norm about gay marriage changed, it emboldened supporters, and prompted many dissenters to shrug their shoulders and accept the new normal. The same principle works in all sorts of places. Take bullying, for example. Betsy has found that norms play a powerful role in encouraging bullying and discouraging it. I've been studying bullying and conflict as it plays out in Americans' public schools. And what kept hitting me was that at some point certain types of conflict and prejudice
你可能还记得当时人们的脸书主页上到处都是彩虹旗。一旦关于同性恋婚姻的社会规范发生变化，它就给了支持者勇气，并促使许多反对者耸耸肩，接受这个新常态。同样的原则在各种地方都起作用。以欺凌为例。贝蒂发现，规范在鼓励和阻止欺凌方面发挥着强大的作用。我一直在研究美国公立学校中发生的欺凌和冲突。一直触动我的是，在某些时候，某些类型的冲突和偏见
become normal to the people who are living there. The central insight of this research is that people go along with the flow rather than their own beliefs. Betsy found the same thing in Rwanda. People who listened to Musek Awayah began supporting intermarriage even if they didn't personally think that intermarriage was a good thing. It all comes back to this idea that what it means to be human is to belong socially to a group.
对于生活在那里的那些人来说已经变得很正常了。这项研究的核心见解是，人们顺应潮流而不是他们自己的信念。贝蒂在卢旺达也发现了同样的情况。收听《穆谢卡瓦亚》的人开始支持通婚，即使他们个人并不认为通婚是一件好事。这一切都回到了这个观点：身为人类的含义就是在社会上归属于一个群体。
And so we're all trying to figure out the rules of those groups. Betsy realized that one unintended way the soap opera had a big effect was that people had listened together. They thought they were just listening to the show, but they were also taking in the reactions of friends and neighbors. When other people expressed dismay as Ruta Ghanira got in the way of the Star Cross lovers,
因此，我们都在试图弄清楚这些群体的规则。贝蒂意识到，这部肥皂剧产生重大影响的一个意想不到的方式是人们是一起收听的。他们以为自己只是在听节目，但他们也在吸收朋友和邻居的反应。当其他人对鲁塔·加尼拉阻碍苦命鸳鸯表达沮丧时，
that sent a message. My fellow Rwandans don't like people like Ruta Ghanira. After the year of testing was over, Betsy's team gave each group a portable stereo and 14 cassette tapes of the radio program. It was ostensibly a reward for volunteering, but it was actually part of the experiment, too. After presenting the stereo, a research assistant suggested that the group could decide how best to share it.
这发出了一条信息。我的卢旺达同胞不喜欢鲁塔·加尼拉这样的人。测试年结束后，贝蒂的团队给每个小组发了一台便携式立体声音响和14盒广播节目的磁带。这表面上是对志愿者的奖励，但实际上也是实验的一部分。赠送音响后，一名研究助理建议小组可以自行决定如何最好地分享它。
In the communities that had been listening to this reconciliation radio program, it was a little bit counterintuitive at first, but they fought more over their common resources that we gave them. And the reason why that was exciting to us is that one of the messages of this radio program was, you should descend against authority. You should make your voice heard. In the communities that had not been listening in a dedicated way to these reconciliation soap operas, basically one person proposed, we give it to the local authority, they will
在一直在收听这个和解广播节目的社区里，起初这有点违反直觉，但他们为我们给他们的共同资源争吵得更多。之所以让我们感到兴奋，是因为这个广播节目的信息之一是：你们应该反抗权威。你们应该发出自己的声音。而在那些没有专门收听这些和解肥皂剧的社区里，基本上是一个人提议说，我们把它交给地方当局，他们会
decide for us. Everyone said, good, and moved on. Among the Mussekiwere group, the discussion was much more lively. Usually someone would make the same proposal. This is what is customary to do in Rwandan communities. But then someone would raise their hand and say, I don't know. The local authority hasn't been coming to listen to all these shows with us.
为我们做决定。每个人都说好，然后就继续了。在穆谢卡维亚小组中，讨论要热烈得多。通常会有人提出同样的建议。这是卢旺达社区惯常的做法。但随后会有人举手说，我不知道。地方当局并没有来和我们一起听所有这些节目。
Why should we sign it over to him? And then maybe someone else would raise their hand and say, I think we should give it to a woman. They are way more responsible than men. And there would be a healthy debate about that. And then people would decide on what to do. So I went back and I said, look, we have caused healthy debate. This is something to celebrate. When I spoke to the Rwandan leader, Alphonse Bakuji recently, it was close to the anniversary
我们为什么要把它交给他？然后可能还会有人举手说，我认为我们应该把它交给一位女性。她们比男性负责得多。然后就会有一场关于这个话题的健康辩论。接着大家会决定该怎么做。所以我回去后说，看，我们引发了健康的辩论。这是值得庆祝的事情。最近当我与卢旺达领导人阿方斯·巴库吉交谈时，正值
of the 1994 genocide. He told me he was incredibly proud of all that Rwandans had accomplished in the intervening quarter century. Mosecawea, along with many other interventions, had made a difference. Irvin's style of accomplished what few scholars ever do. He got to see his ideas put into action. More important, he got to see his ideas make a difference. If there's a continuum of destruction, Irwin helped to show there is also a continuum
1994年大屠杀周年纪念日附近。他告诉我，他为卢旺达人在过去这四分之一个世纪里所取得的一切成就感到无比自豪。《穆谢卡韦亚》以及许多其他干预措施发挥了作用。欧文的风格取得了很少学者能取得的成就。他看到自己的想法付诸实践。更重要的是，他看到自己的想法带来了改变。如果存在一条毁灭的连续体，欧文则有助于表明也存在一条
of benevolence. People can learn tolerance by watching what others do, even fictional characters living on make-believe hilltops. Orvin told me he admires Betsy Pallik's study, but he disagrees with some of her conclusions. Betsy found that people's behavior changed not because their beliefs evolved, but because their perceptions of social norms did. But Orvin thinks it isn't possible to easily separate personal beliefs from one's perception of social norms did. But urban things it isn't possible to easily separate personal beliefs from one's perception of social norms.
仁慈的连续体。人们可以通过观察别人的做法来学习宽容，甚至是生活在虚构山顶上的虚构人物。欧文告诉我，他钦佩贝蒂·帕利克的学习成果，但他不同意她的一些结论。贝蒂发现，人们行为的改变不是因为他们的信念发生了演变，而是因为他们对社会规范的看法发生了变化。但欧文认为，很难把个人信念与一个人对社会规范的看法简单地割裂开来。但欧文认为，很难把个人信念与一个人对社会规范的看法简单地割裂开来。
Let me just say there is no argument about the findings, the results. The only difference between who and me is the interpretation of the results. The results are clear, they are there, and they are meaningful and significant. One point Erwin makes is that Betsy's study was conducted during the first year of the show. By the end of that year, there were many unresolved issues in the narrative. Erwin thinks that if the study had been conducted later, for example, after the villain Ruta Ghanira experiences a change of heart, the study might have picked up changes in people's attitudes, not just their behavior.
请让我声明，对于研究发现和结果，没有任何争论。我和欧文唯一的不同在于对结果的解释。结果很明确，它们就在那里，而且它们是有意义且重大的。欧文提出的观点之一是，贝蒂的研究是在该节目播出的第一年进行的。到那一年结束时，剧本中有许多未解决的问题。欧文认为，如果这项研究是在晚些时候进行的，例如，在反派鲁塔·加尼拉经历转变之后，这项研究可能会捕捉到人们态度的变化，而不仅仅是行为的变化。
Now you might argue that the academics are splitting hairs. I asked Irvin about that. I'm going to play you an extended excerpt from our exchange, because it leads up to something really important. As I said, I think the theoretical differences about why the behavior changed are less important in the fact that behavior actually changed in the direction that was intended. And as you point out, this evaluation was done after one year of a program that lasted now 14 years.
现在你可能会争辩说学者们在吹毛求疵。我问了欧文关于这一点。我将播放我们交流的一个长片段，因为它引出了一些非常重要的事情。正如我所说，我认为关于行为为何改变的理论分歧，不如行为实际上朝着预期方向改变这一事实重要。正如你所指出，这项评估是在一个现在已持续14年的节目的第一年之后完成的。
And those points are very well made. But do you think actually it's important whether the difference comes from norms or beliefs or values, or is it actually just more important that people's behavior changed and who cares what the actual mechanism was? Well, I think that for this, in our case, after one year, what's really important is that behavior changed and some thinking has changed. But there is one reason why it is also important what leads to change. And that is when a society moves towards violence, what we hope is that people understand and can't foresee what's going to happen.
这些观点非常有道理。但你认为这种差异究竟是来自规范、信念还是价值观这重要吗，或者其实更重要的是人们的行为改变了，至于真正的机制是什么谁会在乎呢？嗯，我认为对于这一点，在我们的案例中，在一年之后，真正重要的是行为发生了变化，并且一些思维发生了改变。但为什么是什么导致了改变也很重要，原因只有一个。那就是当一个社会走向暴力时，我们希望人们能够理解并预见到将要发生的事情。
That was one reason we talked to them about the origins of violence. Now, things evolve slowly and at each point a person can say, well, it's just one little thing. I'm not doing anything. And then then the next point, the same thing. But if you can't foresee where this is going to lead, you are more likely to get involved early. Now, if your views depend on social norms, as a society begins to move towards violence, the social norm is that you move together with everybody else towards violence. But if you personally believe that you should take action, then you are more likely to go contrary to the direction of your group. Irwin wants to believe that the values of ordinary Rwandan's changed because he wants to
这是我们与他们讨论暴力起源的原因之一。现在，事情发展得很缓慢，在每个节点上，一个人都可以说，嗯，这只是一件小事。我什么也没做。然后到了下一个节点，同样的事情。但如果你预见不到这会导致什么结果，你就更有可能提早介入。现在，如果你的观点取决于社会规范，随着社会开始走向暴力，社会规范就是你和大家一起走向暴力。但如果你个人认为你应该采取行动，那么你就更有可能违背你所在群体的方向。
believe that the transformation in Rwanda is here to stay, that if hatred were to start broadcasting again, ordinary Rwandans would stand up to it because they now have different values. But if Betsy is right, this means that Rwandans began acting in a more tolerant fashion and large part because tolerance became the new social norm. This raises a troubling question. If social norms can change in a matter of months from hate to tolerance. Can't they go back just as easily in the other direction? Betsy study provides an important lesson and not just for people in Rwanda. The currents that govern human behavior are fickle.
欧文希望相信普通卢旺达人的价值观已经改变，因为他希望相信卢旺达的转型将会持久，如果仇恨再次开始广播，普通的卢旺达人会站出来抵制，因为他们现在有了不同的价值观。但如果贝蒂是对的，这就意味着卢旺达人开始表现得更加宽容，很大程度上是因为宽容成为了新的社会规范。这引发了一个令人不安的问题。如果社会规范能在几个月内从仇恨转变为宽容。它们难道不能同样容易地朝着另一个方向倒退吗？贝蒂的研究提供了一个重要的教训，不仅仅是对卢旺达人。左右人类行为的潮流是反复无常的。
If you want to make change and then preserve it, you need to be eternally vigilant. After several years of will they or won their drama, Shema and Bhattamurisa finally get married. Ruandans got so excited about the wedding, about the forbidden love between these two villages that they wanted to witness an actual wedding. They demanded that the producers of the radio show hold a wedding in the national stadium so that the whole country could show up to watch.
如果你想做出改变并将其保持下去，你需要永远保持警惕。经过几年“他们会在一起吗，还是不会”的戏剧性情节，谢马和巴塔穆里萨终于结婚了。卢旺达人对这场婚礼、对这两个村庄之间这段被禁忌的爱感到如此兴奋，以至于他们想亲眼见证一场真正的婚礼。他们要求广播节目的制作人在国家体育场举办一场婚礼，以便全国人民都能到场观看。
Here's the director, André Musagara. We told them, Shema and the Atomizas wedding can be take place at the National Stadium because they have many friends. So if you want to take part in their wedding, this is the way you are going to do it. You dress very, very well and you go to someone you are in the conflict with and you reconcile Sama yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakia, yung mwakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakakak It is the fruit of love for your neighbor. Be the fast to maintain them. Where these hatred, they do not grow. Where they love, they grow and flourish. For Andre Moussagara and the other creators of the show, the goal is to keep that message going as long as the audience is interested. Moussake Wea is now in its 16th year and shows no signs of stopping. It's a soap opera. The twists are endless.
这是导演安德烈·穆萨加拉。我们告诉他们，谢马和阿塔米萨的婚礼可以在国家体育场举行，因为他们有很多朋友。所以如果你想参加他们的婚礼，这就是你要做的方式。你穿得非常非常整洁，然后去找一个与你有冲突的人并与人和解。萨马... 这是爱邻居的果子。争做维护者。有仇恨的地方，它们就不会生长。有爱的地方，它们就会生长繁荣。对于安德烈·穆萨加拉和该剧的其他创作者来说，目标是只要观众感兴趣，就一直保持这个信息。《穆谢卡韦亚》现在已经进入第16个年头，而且没有停止的迹象。这是一部肥皂剧。转折永无止境。
Today's show was produced by Matthew Schwartz and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Pat Shah, Laura Quarell, Thomas Liu, and Kat Shipnick. Jackson Wungani did our voiceovers and translations. Special thanks to Radio Labinevelencia, the Dutch NGO that spearheaded the creation of Mussekawaya and got us in touch with the writers of the show and Rwandan leaders. Our unsung heroes this week are Natasha Branch and Alex Drovenskis from NPR's audio engineering team. Natasha and Alex pitched in when we were having some challenges with our audio for this week's
今天的节目由马修·施瓦茨制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕特·沙阿、劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘和卡特·希普尼克。杰克逊·温加尼负责我们的配音和翻译。特别感谢Radio Labinevelencia，这个荷兰非政府组织牵头创建了《穆谢卡韦亚》，并让我们与该剧的编剧和卢旺达领导人取得了联系。我们本周无名英雄是来自NPR音频工程团队的娜塔莎·布兰奇和亚历克斯·德罗文斯基。当我们本周的节目音频遇到一些挑战时，娜塔莎和亚历克斯挺身而出。
show. They helped us troubleshoot the problems and did so with calm and good cheer. Thank you so much for the help Natasha and Alex. You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们帮助我们排查了问题，并且表现得冷静和充满活力。非常感谢娜塔莎和亚历克斯的帮助。你可以在脸书和推特上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。